hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show here's what's making the news today
at least four die in New Zealand after
record rainfall causes flooding and
landslides in the city of Auckland
we'll tell you about an ancient Woodland
saved by the local community in
southeast London
but how a backpack designed by a 12 year
old could protect people from air
pollution
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis at least four people have died in
flash floods and landslides in New
Zealand's biggest city Auckland a state
of emergency was declared in the city on
Friday and across large parts of the
North Island after an entire Summer's
worth of rain fell in just eight hours
climate change has led to more common
and intense downpours in New Zealand in
the country's new prime minister Chris
hipkin says more rain is expected
my focus and the focus of central
government is supporting Auckland
through what is still um you know a big
challenge ahead of them there's a big
cleanup to go and of course we know
through the forecasts that there's more
bad weather ahead
let's talk to Liz Bentley now she's the
chief executive of the royal
Meteorological Society Liz thank you so
much for talking to us here on the daily
climate show just how much rain have
they had in New Zealand and how does
that compare to previous years
well so this is a record-breaking an
unprecedented rainfall event for New
Zealand as you say a season's worth
three months worth of rain fell in just
a space of a few hours so looking at
some of the numbers there were about
260 millimeters of rain fairly in about
an 18 hour period for for Auckland
itself so unprecedented it's been
described as a one in a hundred year
event but as our climate's changing
these one in 100 Year events are just
becoming much more frequent and that
amount of rain we've seen the widespread
flooding that we've had but also the
landslides as well so the impact has
been very significant for that country
are they prepared to deal with that it
doesn't seem that anyone could possibly
be prepared for dealing with an entire
Summer's worth of rain in just one day
no absolutely and it is a challenge and
a challenge that we're going to have to
deal with to make our cities much more
resilient to these extreme rainfall
events and I've heard the term sponge
cities being mentioned uh so how can we
make our our cities able to absorb I
guess that much rainfall falling in such
a short space of time so we need to
think about the the materials that we
use so Greening up cities with
grasslands and trees in the in the city
center because these structures actually
just absorb the rainfall and percolate
it into the ground rather than say
concrete surfaces which just the
rainfall just runs off we're also going
to have to think about sewage systems so
much bigger drains to take the capacity
of rainfall and much larger pipes in the
sewage systems to take that that
rainfall away and I think this is the
description of these sponge cities that
can adapt and be much more resilient in
extreme rainfall events
and as we heard Chris Hipkins say just
there more rainfall is expected in New
Zealand
yeah more rain in the forecast over the
next few days and although the levels of
rainfall that is expected to fall are
not as great as we've seen in the last
few days any further rain falling on
those saturated ground is really going
to cause further problems so with the
cleaner pact it underway at the moment
it's going to become a real challenge
for them over the course of the next few
days
these changes in weather patterns and
indeed more extreme weather is that
something that we're seeing across the
world I'm just thinking of how here in
the UK it's been extremely cold just
recently
yeah so if we look at rainfall in
particular you know our climate has
already changed we're already seeing
more extreme rainfall events happening
and that's because a warmer climate a
warmer atmosphere can hold more moisture
so when we get these rainfall events
they're more intense and they're
happening more frequently so typically a
one degree warming in the global average
temperature leads to about a seven
percent increase in the amount of
moisture that the atmosphere can hold
and we've already seen about a 1.2
degree warming of our global
temperatures so you can see that extra
moisture is already there and we'll
continue to to increase as our climate
continues to change so we're going to
have to become much more resilient here
in the UK and elsewhere around the world
at dealing with these extreme rainfall
events okay Liz thank you so much thanks
for talking to us
thank you
all right well let's have a look at some
of today's other climate news now and
motoring experts say the government
should give drivers incentives to buy
second-hand electric cars or risk
falling short of their climate targets
demand for used electric vehicles is
falling primarily because the cost of
fuel is going down and the cost of
electricity it's going up the
government's office for zero emission
Vehicles has created a working group to
examine the used electric car market
including how to stimulate more demand
residents of broccoli in southeast
London have raised over a hundred
thousand pounds to save corn wood which
is a rare surviving patch of ancient
Woodland it was at risk of being torn
down for housing by developers now the
wood is a habitat for lots of different
Wildlife including slow worms and
endangered hedgehogs Community
campaigners led by the fourth Reserve
Foundation raised the money through
school cake sales protests sponsored
bike rides and local concerts
and a school students designed for a
backpack that can filter air to protect
people from pollution and airborne
disease has won a national Innovation
contest twelve-year-old Eleanor Woods
was presented with a real world
incarnation of her backpack in London
it's powered by solar energy and has a
built-in filter and fans to clean the
air
and just before we go we want your
climate questions anything that's ever
mystified you